consider this game even strikes Bob to
go into a room the room is empty except
for some locks an empty box and a single
deck of cards Eve tells Bob to select a
card from the deck and then hide the
card as best he can
rules are simple Bob cannot leave the
room with anything and he can put at
most one card in the box he wins the
game if Eve is unable to determine his
card
what is his best strategy Bob selects
his card six of diamonds and throws it
in the box
at first he considers the different
types of locks maybe he should lock the
card in the box with the key Eve can
pick locks so he considers the
combination lock it seems like the best
choice but suddenly he realizes a
problem the remaining cards leak
information about his choice since it's
now missing from the deck the locks are
a decoy he shouldn't separate the card
from the deck he returns his card to the
deck and shuffles the deck to randomize
it shuffling is the best lock because it
leaves no information about his choice
it's now equally likely to be any card
in the deck he can now leave the cards
openly in confidence he wins the game
because the best Eve can do is simply
guess he has left no information about
his choice every card is equally likely
to be the card he picked most
importantly even if we give Eve
unlimited computational help she can't
do any better when this is the case we
can say we have achieved perfect secrecy
on September 1st 1945 29 year-old Claude
Shannon published this idea in a
classified paper he thinks about it as
follows imagine Alice writes a message
to Bob 20 letters long this is
equivalent to picking one specific page
from the message space the message space
can be thought of as a complete
collection of all possible 20 letter
messages anything you can think of as a
page in the stack next Alice applies the
shared key which is a list of 20
randomly generated shifts between 1 and
26 the key space is the complete
collection of all possible outcomes
generating the key is equivalent to
selecting a page from this stack at
random when she applies the shifts to
encrypt the message she ends up with a
ciphertext
the ciphertext space represents all
possible results of an encryption when
she applies the key and maps to a unique
page in this stack notice the size of
the message space is equal to the size
of the key space and ciphertext space so
if Eve has access to a page of
ciphertext the only thing she knows is
that every message is equally likely no
amount of computational power will help
improve a blind guess this defines
perfect secrecy the problem with the
one-time pad is that we have to share
long random keys in advance to solve
this problem we need to relax our
definition of secrecy by developing a
definition of pseudo randomness
when we observe the physical world we
find random processes everywhere we can
generate truly random numbers by
measuring random fluctuations known as
noise when we measure this noise known
as sampling we can obtain numbers for
example if we measure the electric
current of TV static over time we will
generate a truly random sequence we can
visualize this random sequence by
drawing a path that changes direction
according to each number known as a
random walk notice a lack of pattern at
all scales at each point in the sequence
the next move is always unpredictable
random processes are said to be
non-deterministic since they are
impossible to determine in advance
machines on the other hand are
deterministic their operation is
predictable and repeatable in 1946 John
von Neumann was involved in running
computations for the military
more specifically the design of the
hydrogen bomb using a computer called
the ENIAC he planned to repeatedly
calculate approximations of the process
involved in nuclear fission this
required quick access to randomly
generated numbers that could be repeated
if needed
however the Aniak had very limited
internal memory storing long random
sequences was not possible so Neumann
developed an algorithm to mechanically
simulate the scrambling aspect of
randomness first select a truly random
number called the seed this number can
come from the measurement of noise for
the current time in milliseconds
the seed is provided as input to a
simple calculation multiply the seed by
itself then output the middle of this
result then use the output as the next
seed and repeat the process as many
times as needed this is known as the
middle squares method and is the first
of a long line of pseudo-random number
generators they all follow the same
principle except a short random seed and
expand it into a long sequence the
randomness of the sequence is dependent
on the randomness of the initial seed
only same seed same sequence what are
differences between a randomly generated
versus pseudo randomly generated
sequence if we represent each sequence
as a random walk they seem similar until
we speed things up the pseudo-random
sequence must eventually repeat this
occurs when the algorithm reaches a seed
it previously used and the cycle repeats
the length before a pseudo-random
sequence repeats is called the period
the period is strictly limited by the
length of the seed for example if we use
a two-digit seed then an algorithm can
produce at most a hundred digits before
reusing a seed and repeating the cycle a
three-digit seed can expand past a
thousand digits before repeating a
4-digit can expand past 10,000 digits if
we use a seed large enough the sequence
can expand into trillions of digits
before repeating making it harder to
distinguish between the two the key
difference is important when you
generate a number pseudo randomly there
are many sequences which cannot occur
if Alice generates a truly random
sequence of 20 shifts it's equivalent to
a uniform selection from the stack of
all possible sequences of shifts this
stack contains 26 to the power of 20
pages which is astronomical in size if
we stood at the bottom and shine a light
upwards a person at the top would not
see the light for around 200 million
years
compare this to Alice generating a 20
digit pseudo-random sequence using a
four digit random seed this is
equivalent to a uniform selection from
10,000 possible initial seeds meaning
she can generate one of the 10,000
possible sequences a tiny fraction of
all possible sequences when we move from
random to pseudo-random ships we shrink
the key space into a much smaller seed
space for a pseudo-random sequence to be
indistinguishable from a randomly
generated sequence
it must be impractical for a computer to
try all seeds and look for a match this
leads to an important distinction in
computer science between what is
possible versus what is possible in a
reasonable amount of time we use the
same logic when we lock up our bike we
know anyone can simply try all possible
combinations until they find a match but
it would take them days to do so so for
eight hours we lock up our bike we
assume it's practically safe with
pseudo-random generators the security
increases as the length of the seed
increases if the most powerful computer
would take hundreds of years to run
through all seeds then we safely can
assume it's practically secure instead
of perfectly secure as computers get
faster the seed size must increase
accordingly pseudo randomness frees
Alice and Bob from sharing all of their
random shifts in advance instead they
share a short random seed and expand it
into the same random looking sequence
when needed
but what happens if they can never meet
to share the seed